and that's really what they use as you
know their talking points to say oh he's
such a great Governor well is he right
now we have the highest uh homeowner
homeowner insurance rates in the entire
country the average rate is about
Seventeen hundred dollars nationally and
in Florida it's six thousand dollars or
more okay and after this year it's
expected to jump another 40 to 60
percent we have some of the highest
utility bills in the entire country as
well which have increased over 20
percent in the last year and that's all
because Ron DeSantis accepted millions
of dollars of campaign donations from
the utility companies like FPL that's
Florida Power and Light as well as the
insurance companies and he actually
allowed for the uh insurance industry to
participate in writing the insurance
bill that uh that made it so that
homeowners in Florida can't really Sue
anymore right they can't really sue for
fraud and so what you have now is this
massive homeowner insurance crisis and
it's unaffordable people can't even
afford uh their homeowner insurance
rates